ABCs of AI Q is for Quantum error
correction Quantum error correction is
an algorithm known to identify and fix
errors in quantum computers due to
Quantum noise noise refers to all of the
things that can cause interference in a
quantum computer like signals from Wi-Fi
or other disturbances from Earth's
magnetic field reducing noise is super
important in creating a functional
quantum computer because it'll reduce
the amount of Errors which can lead to
incorrect or even useless outputs
earlier this year for the first time
ever Google Quant AI researchers have
experimentally demonstrated that it's
possible to reduce errors by increasing
the number of cbits check out more on
this Breakthrough by searching Quantum
error correction on blog. gooogle and
that's all for this episode of